en Francia desde 2005 la leches leonity
estableció un marco para el final de la
vida la ley prohíbe el uso excesivo de
tratamientos para mantener cándida a un
enfermo desesperado los médicos pueden
decidir interrumpir los cuidados con el
acuerdo del paciente y de forma
consensuada la ley se modificó en 2016
para permitir el uso de sedación
profunda y continúa a aplicarse para los
pacientes terminales esta ley es la
consecuencia de una tragedia el caso
Amber en septiembre de 2000 Este joven
bombero fue víctima de un grave
accidente de tráfico de trapléjico ciego
y mudo pero perfectamente lúcido
consiguió formular su petición de morir
escribiendo una carta al entonces
presidente pero este se negó con el
acuerdo de la familia Pero ilegalmente
su médico le provocó la muerte en
septiembre de 2003 fue inculpado junto a
la madre de van antes de ser liberados
tres años después
unos años más tarde otro caso
cristalizará el debate sobre el final de
la vida El de Van Sound lamberg una
familia destrozada ante toda Francia por
el destino de uno de los suyos Danzón
tetrapléjico y en estado vegetativo
desde 2008 sus médicos decidieron
interrumpir sus cuidados en 2013 una
petición de su esposa y de algunos de
sus hermanos y hermanas su madre y su
padre fervientes católicos se opusieron
siguió una batalla legal de más de 10
años en julio de 2019 pocos días después
del cese definitivo de los cuidados
falleció este episodio reveló los
profundos desacuerdos en torno al final
de la vida en Francia tras tres meses y
medio de trabajo la gran mayoría de los
miembros de la convención ciudadana
llamaron a legalizar la asistencia
activa a morir mientras una minoría
considera que podría ser usado en contra
de personas vulnerables
serán recibidos el lunes por el
presidente francés que sigue siendo muy
evasivo sobre el tema y que deberá
decidir Cuál es el próximo paso